in today's agile business environment
business analysis holds the key to
unlocking the real value of business
data organizations all over the world
are looking for business analysts who
can use the wealth of data available and
employ cutting-edge techniques to reveal
actionable insights for increasing
revenue productivity and efficiency
across the enterprise
hi i'm ravi bapna the curtis l carlson
chair of business analytics
and i'd like to welcome you to the
business analytics bootcamp offered by
the carlson school of management
university of minnesota
in collaboration with simply learn
since its establishment in 1919
university of minnesota's carlson school
of management has been a leader in
business education and served as a
beacon of knowledge for the world's
business community
in this business analytics boot camp
you'll learn the theoretical
underpinnings of analytics and gain the
practical know-how to quickly and
successfully apply the right tools
techniques new problems
tackled by business today
with this program you stand to learn and
master all the key skills needed by a
business analyst today
understand the tools and techniques used
in business analysis planning and
monitoring learn powerful ms excel
skills to leverage business analytics
and make better business decisions learn
and apply essential statistical and sql
concepts gain an in-depth understanding
of r and learn to write your own r
scripts
define understand and use apply
functions and dplyr functions
understand and use the hypothesis
testing method linear and non-linear
regression models and classification
techniques
learn to visualize data using tableau
and power bi
and much more
along with carlson's expertise
simplylearn's applied learning approach
provides the best elements of
traditional classroom education
delivered online blended learning
combines self-paced e-learning
instructor-led live virtual classrooms
hands-on labs and projects with 24 7
learning support what's more simple
learn's platform provides ample
peer-to-peer interaction with your
fellow learners
this program fits into your budget and
your schedule you access all aspects of
the program from your own home or office
and the cost is a fraction of the
tuition and expenses of an equivalent
on-campus program what are you waiting
for get in touch with one of our program
advisors who will walk you through the
application process